This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Here's a question we get asked all the time. How do you change someone's behavior? Now, awesome would it be if you, the victim, decided to not get upset? Experts trying to change the way we live our lives. The biggest single cause of global warming, along with deforestation, which is 20% of it, is the burning of fossil fuels. Oil is a problem and coal is the most
serious problem. President is trying to reshape our culture. For we have a choice in this country, we can accept a politics that breeds division or we can come together and say not this time. We like to think we change people's behavior through information, through education, through persuasion. Now these things often don't work, but we keep doing them because we have an unshakable faith in a core assumption about human nature. If you want to shape how people behave, you must first change the way they think. Today we look at a very different approach.
One that will take us on a journey from the outskirts of Budapest in 1944 to the hills of Rwanda a half century later. This week on Hidden Brain, how to change behavior, it's not what you think. When Irvin's style was a small child, his family had a living caretaker named Maria Gogan. Irvin had his own name for her. We call her March, which is an abbreviation of the Hungarian word Marchka, which means cat. That's because much told Irvin and his sister bedtime stories and sometimes, as she told these stories, she'd curl up at the foot of the bed and fall asleep. Outside that cozy house, things were very different. Irvin faced a
dangerous world. You see, Irvin was not just a six-year-old child, but... A six-year-old Jewish child, of course. Hungary was not a friendly place to be Jewish. Since the 1920s, the Hungarian government had passed a series of anti-Jewish laws, restricting Jews from certain occupations, stripping them of the right to vote, prohibiting intermarriage with non-Jews. When World War II erupted, Irvin and his family were in grave danger. Irvin remembers walking with March, pushing his
little sister down the street in a baby carriage. He heard a massive rumbling and turned to see German tanks rolling down the street. In 1944, Germans occupied the country. With the help of hundreds of thousands of Hungarian citizens, they rounded up the country's dues. As nearly half a million people were dragged off to places like Auschwitz, most Hungarians did nothing to help. They simply watched as their friends and neighbors disappeared. Irwin's father was captured. Young Irwin might have faced the same fate, but someone intervened to help.
It was Maria, or much. She took my sister and me into hiding with a Christian family. To feed the children and their mother, much would carry large amounts of dough and the baby carriage to the bakery, and then come back with freshly baked loaves. But one day Hungarian Nazis saw all the bread that she was carrying and they got suspicious. They stopped her.
They told her that if she's going to have juice, she will be killed, had her stand at the wall with her hands up for a very long time. Eventually, a man from the neighborhood, a well-respected Hungarian Nazi, saw what was happening, and he told the others to stop. One might think that after such a terrifying experience, March might have stopped helping the stop family. But she kept on. And she continued to do the same thing for the rest of the time.
Much also found out where Irwin's father was being held in a forced labour camp. She went there and approached the wire fencing. She asked someone to summon Irwin's dad. Through the fence, she told him where she had taken the children. So when the whole group from this forced labour camp was taken to Germany, they had a stop over in Budapest and during that stop over my father escaped. His father found the house with Irwin and his sister. They all hid together and managed to survive the war.
Irwin is very sure that March saved his life and the lives of his immediate family. Other relatives who didn't have someone like March to help them, perished. My father's sister and her two children were killed in Auschwitz. My mother's sister's husband, my uncle uncle died in a forced labor camp. As Irwin grew up, he found himself dwelling on the question, why do people do terrible things to one another?
And is it possible to stop them? Irwin eventually got a PhD in psychology from Stanford and taught clinical psychology at Harvard University. All the while, he kept researching how the Nazis dehumanized the Jews as a stepping stone to genocide. He studied the factors that led to Hitler's rise and Nazi ideology. Evil leaders can get people riled up, but the spark of hate usually doesn't turn into a fire unless people are also experiencing difficult life conditions. So if Germany had not been in the terrible state that it was in, losing a war, a revolution, people in groups fighting on the streets for years, a tremendous depression. If Germany hadn't had that combined with the history of devaluation of Jews, then it is unlikely that Hitler would have been heard.
It's unlikely that Hitler's maniacal, intense, but charismatic capacity to talk to people would have had the kind of effects that it did. So yes, evil people are important, but not alone. Bad leaders don't alone create it. Irvin developed a theory of how genocide comes about. As leaders spread hateful ideologies and as people get used to ostracizing others, hostility between groups slowly evolves into violence. Irvin came up with a term for this gradual process, the continuum of destruction. Violence evolves. There is experimental research that shows that when a person engages in violent action, they are likely to engage in more and greater violence.
In studying a variety of genocide and mass killings, I saw this in every case that people get devalued. The evaluation is justified in terms of the ideology, in reference to the ideology that these people stand in the way of us creating this better world. So this is very important to understand and very important to try to counteract. Irwin tried to imagine what might have stopped this much to violence. From his own experience, he knew that active
bystanders can have a huge impact in saving the lives of victims. But in any conflict, why do some bystanders choose to intervene while so many others stay silent? Why had march taken such great risks to save Irvin and his family. I think she did it because she loved us, because she was connected to us, because she saw us as human beings and didn't accept and go along with the devaluation of Jews that was part of the society at that time. Close personal relationships between Jews and Christians
could inoculate people against stereotypes and prejudice. The close relationship that March had had with him and his family made it possible for her to see Jews as human beings worthy of protection. At a very young age, she was sent out to work as a servant in other families. And she made very good connections to children. And I think to the people she worked for, and she received a lot of love and care from these children back in return
for her love. That was a very important healing experience on her part. So all of these things, I think, contributed to the kind of person she became and her openness and readiness to be altruistic. Irvin felt that his personal experiences provided a roadmap to combat hatred. He started to think about how to inoculate people against hate speech and intolerance. He traveled the world, sharing his ideas at academic conferences. He became a renowned expert on the causes of genocide. You know, when this process begins, when a society begins to harm some group and devalues it more and justifies it and then creates institutions and there is this evolution, the only thing that can stop it is active by
standards. People who are witnesses, who see what is happening and who feel a responsibility and who begin to take action against it. And unfortunately, much of the time on a whole scale, this doesn't happen. But there are wonderful instances when it does. And there are many examples of even single individuals doing things that changes the course of a society. Fifty years after March saved Irwin's life, he began hearing about an unfolding disaster in the East African country of Rwanda.
A radio station was broadcast in urgent messages to the population of 7 million. Very few recordings of these broadcasts exist today. Here's one. Rwanda belongs to those who truly defended, I want to go to the river. I want to go to the river. I want to go to the river. Rwanda belongs to those who truly defended and you, the cockroaches, are not Rwandans. The cockroaches will not escape. Rwanda belongs to those who truly defended and you, the cockroaches, are not Rwandans. The cockroaches will not escape. Rwanda belongs to those who truly defended and you, the cockroaches, are not Rwandans.
The cockroaches were exterminated, God is never unfair. Just as the Nazis portrayed Jews as subhuman, the Rwandan government dominated by the Houtou group dehumanized the Tutsi minority. Their weapon of choice, radio, or a some call it, hate radio. The broadcast had a real effect. One Harvard study calculated that hate radio convinced an additional 50,000 people to murder their neighbors. Human rights experts Samantha Power described this in this way.
Killer is often carried a machete in one hand and a transistor radio in the other. Radio and machete, as the French historian Jean-Pierre Crétien put it, the first to give and receive orders, the second to execute them. I was 29. I had to move by night, you know, freeing through bushes under water. This is Andre Musagara.
During the genocide, Andre lived in Kigali, Rwanda's capital city. He talked to us on Skype from Rwanda. He told me armed men came to his house and dragged everyone outside. You know, you know, say that, remember, they took us outside holding our hands up. I don't know why they came. We had bruised the doors and the curtains they put on. Andre fully expected to be killed. I don't know what prevented them from killing us
because they were having these traditional waypans and whatever, whatever. I was not killed. I asked Andre how many people came to his house with machetes. He had a hard time answering. I couldn't even look at them, straightening the eyes, they were so terrible. It's like they didn't want anyone to identify them,
so they were saying lay down and whatever. Yeah, it was a hard moment. identify them so they would sing lay down and they would do one with that. It was a hard moment. Upheaval in the African state of Rwanda. This is all the streets of Rwanda today. The Red Cross takes the death toll on the tens of thousands. Almost a half million tutuses and moderate tutus have been massacred by another half million.
Roving hands of drunk youngsters carrying machetes at soldiers is at genocide and what is being done to stop the killing. I don't want to remember about this. By the time the Rwandan patriotic front defeated the Huto government a few months later, the country was in ruins. As many as a million people had been murdered, the majority of the Tutsi population was dead. Many of their killers were roaming free. And now the nation had to rebuild.
How can a country come back from such devastation? Would it ever be possible to rebuild trust? For Irwin's tab, it all seemed eerily familiar. A genocide had unfolded, and yet again, the world had sat on its hands and done nothing. I remember seeing pictures of bodies of people killed floating down rivers. And I do remember being very upset that nobody was doing anything. The community of nations wasn't doing anything. That the
United States was stepping aside. Many countries weren't just stepping aside. They were actively turning a blind eye. In Rwanda, when the genocide began, many countries sent in military missions to take their own nationals out. The evacuation of American citizens is proceeding smoothly. French troops have entered the capital of Pigà,
to evacuate French nationals. Belgian troops are reported to be on say. Some 300 US Marines are standing by in Burundi to help with evacuations if needed. They flew them out and, in a sense, communicated to the perpetrators that we are not involved, you are free to do whatever you do. If we completely exterminate the cockroaches, nobody in the world will judge us.
Irvin had been speaking at conferences around the world about the causes of genocide, the trauma faced by survivors, and how to work toward reconciliation. But the news from Rwanda told him it was time to try to put into action the theories he had spent decades developing. Simply giving speeches was not enough. Irvin felt he had to act. He and his partner, trauma specialist Laurie Pearlman,
got on a plane and went to Rwanda. There was a real risk that violence could flare up again. We definitely, clearly, went with the intention of creating the program that tries to help, that tries to promote healing, tries to promote reconciliation, so that people live better lives, and ties to prevent future violence. Preventing future violence, it was something that Alphonse Bacussi was thinking about as well. He was director of Rwanda's conflict management department, like every other Rwandan, Alphonse had himself been affected by the genocide. Now, even as he came to terms with his own
suffering, he was given the task of trying to heal the wounds of his people. I spoke to Alphonse recently on a scratchy phone line to Kigali. So you are affected and you are asked to hit people. So you're affected but you also have to simultaneously help the people who are affected, other people who are affected. That is why I'm saying about Daed Mah. As he battled his dilemma, Alphonse dug deep into his past back to happier days before the genocide. He went back to his time in college in high school, and
he remembered one thing that he had loved as a student, the theatre. The festival in my second at the school I used to play some drama. I was in... I was one of the to act in my team. It was clear that radio could convince people to be violent. Rwandan officials, Irvin and a production team led by a Dutch NGO, Radio Labine Valencia, wanted to prove that radio could also bring people together. The idea they came up with? A radio, so popular.
Rwandan officials had successfully used an educational drama to teach people how to practice safe sex. Alphonse, Irvin and the production team thought that a radio drama could teach ordinary citizens how to spot and then reverse the early stages of the continuum of destruction. Irvin had about a dozen messages he wanted to sprinkle throughout the show, all were derived from nearly 50 years of research and reflected his own experiences during the Holocaust. We're going to look at three of those messages. First, violence evolves slowly. Genocidal leaders don't always start out planning to commit genocide. At the beginning, they are not so committed. The vision that we are going to kill these people is not there.
That evolves part of this evolution. Point number two, bystanders matter. In conditions that need to great violence, bystanders have to act early. Because the later it is, the more leaders and the society gets committed to turning against and harming these people. Number three, when people form close personal relationships with those from other groups, this provides a barrier to the spread of prejudice. When two people from unfriendly groups marry one another, this can reduce hostility between the groups,
or when wanted to convey this very simple message. The hope that internal marriage would be a positive thing. The production team assembled a group of writers to develop the right narrative. The brainstorming sessions span hours, days, weeks. Ours and hours and hours, looking over the hills of Kigali, developing this original radio program. this original radio program. In 2004, one decade after genocide had devastated the country, the program made its debut. It was called... When we come back,
we'll hear about the Rwandan love story that captivated a divided country. The question was, would it work? I'm Shankar Vidantam and you're listening to Hidden Brain. This is NPR. I'm Shankar Vidantam and this is... Just kidding, this is Hidden Brain. The radio soap opera Musaik Awair, which means new dawn, was making its debut.
The show follows two fictional villages, Muhumoro and Bumanzi, with a backstory that inevitably leads to conflict. Here's producer George Weiss, who led the NGO Radio Lab in Avalencia that launched the program. We located these two places on two hills opposite one another and in the middle there is a field which is fertile and through some historic injustice was given to the second village, Bumanzi. And then a little catastrophe happens, a bridge collapses, somebody gets killed, and people start feeling very insecure.
This is in parallel to Irwin Staupp's, what he calls, difficult life conditions. Irwin Staupp knew from his own experience during the Holocaust that difficult life conditions provide fertile soil for hatred to grow. Musicawea combine Irwin's research into the causes of genocide with Alphonse Paguzi's background in theatre. The hope was, in the fictitious conflict between the Muhumoro and the Bomancy, who do's and tootsies in the audience would recognize their own story. And they might learn three concrete ways to move past their divisions.
As the Rwandan writers and producers created the drama, one member of the team was... Andrei Musagara. Yes, that's the same Andrei who survived the genocide, who didn't know why the men with machetes didn't kill him, who didn't want to be reminded of that traumatic moment. Today, Andrei is the director of Musekiawea. So, to some extent, it opened my mind and now I am different from the guy I was using
yellow side and even before. Andre and the other Rowanden writers try to weave psychological messages into their narrative. Violence evolves slowly. Bystanders matter. Intermarriage can reduce conflict. Over the past 14 years, there have been more than 700 episodes, each one about 20 minutes long. At a story workshop at the beginning of each season, the writers decide how the plot is going to evolve all while weaving in the messages approved by the academic team they are working with.
Ruadhan society has worked hard over the past 25 years to try and erase the divisions between Houtu and Tutsi to ensure that tribal rivalries never again put lives in danger. Here I'm speaking with showwriter Charles Rokundo. Can I ask you I don't know if this is appropriate to ask you or not so forgive me if it's not appropriate but were you from the Houtu community or the Tutsi community? I wonder, I wonder, I wonder, in one it's very difficult. In Rwanda it's frowned upon to discuss the Houtu or Tutsi past. In some cases, you can even be jailed under a law prohibiting something called divisionism.
The official position of the Rwandan government is that there is no ethnicity there. Everyone is Rwandan. In the soap opera, as hostilities flared between the communities on two opposing hills, the writers needed characters for listeners to identify with. So on those two hill tops, both alike in dignity, they created a pair of star cross lovers, Shema and Batamurisa. What are you saying? What are you saying? I'm going to tell you something about Batamurisa. I'm not saying that, I'm saying that. I'm saying that.
I'm saying that I'm not saying that. People are very interested in love. So by telling them this love story, they are easily connected. And through this story, they could learn that above the differences, they can find something to unite the way more. Yeah. Andrei explains that Mosecawea is a Romeo and Julia type story differences they can find something to unite them. Andrei explains that Mosekiawea is a Romeo and Julia type story where young lovers have to battle the animosity their families feel toward each other.
Just like Shakespeare's Montague's and Capulets, the romance causes all kinds of conflict between the two hills. The show was a runaway success. In Rwanda, nearly everyone listens to the radio and researchers have estimated that most of the population was listening to Mosekawaya. Anyone associated with the show became a big star and it seemed like the messages were getting through, at least anecdotally. One of the show's villains is a man named Ruta Ghanira. He's wary of the other side, he thinks they are stealing crops, keeping his village down. The name Ruta Ghanira became used in casual conversation
when someone was acting like a jerk. Here's producer George Weiss. Well, we heard people describe conflict situations by using the names of our characters. You know, oh, you don't be a Ruta Ganeera. It seemed like the Rwandans were getting the message. But were they really? How could the show creators know for sure? Enter social scientist Betsy Palak, who is now a professor
of psychology at Princeton University. I was sitting in New Haven at Yale University, and I found a report about this radio cell pop-up. At the time, Betsy was a graduate student, trying to figure out a topic for her PhD field research. She reached out to the show creators. They agreed to work with her to measure whether the show was changing people's beliefs
and making them more tolerant toward each other. Betsy wanted to do something very ambitious, conduct a controlled study in a country that had just been through an incredibly brutal civil war. Remember, the creators of the show wanted to convince Rowandins about three things. Violence evolved slowly, bystanders matter, intermarriage reduces conflict. But were the messages getting through, were Rowandins adopting these new beliefs? Betsy wanted to measure the changes, and she wanted to know where the ordinary people were treating their fellow citizens differently. We ran it like a medical trial in which we assigned certain communities to listen to
this reconciliation, so Bobbra, and other communities to listen to a different so Bobbra that was about a different topic, specifically HIV AIDS and Women's Health. So once a month, for an entire year, the Musaikawaya group gathered around a portable stereo and listened. They listened as Batamuriza's father died and Shema came to pay his respects. They listened as Batamuriza fell in love with the forbidden Shema. They listened as heavy rain destroyed a bridge between the hilltops. As Ruta Ghanira's son died from malnutrition and he blamed the other village for the death. As Ruta Ghanira ran for office
and planned to invade the other village. As all this happened, people listened. And as is often the case in Rwandan society, they listened together in groups. They weren't just hearing the story on their own. They were seeing the reactions on the faces of their friends and neighbors. They wept together. They laughed together. They shouted out in encouragement when Bhatamurisa was dejected. Ihangane Shah, meaning hold on dear. After one year, Betsy and her team interviewed the volunteers and measured their beliefs.
Had they learned the lessons, had their attitudes to what other Rwandans changed, Betsy asked them about Irvin's three ideas that the Rwandan writers were trying to instill. Number one, genocide doesn't happen suddenly. The radio program taught that violence accumulates slowly. It doesn't happen all at once. I saw this in every case. Violence progressively evolves. People get devalued. There was just one problem.
The listeners in the study? They disagreed. We had a number of people who were in our study who said to us at the end, I don't think that's true. The way the genocide happened for me, it came like a sudden rain. Lesson number two, bystanders matter. It was one of Irvin's most important guiding principles,
the thing he had learned from much, the woman who had saved him during the Holocaust. When a society begins to harm some group, the only thing that can stop it is actually bystanders. But here too, the idea that bystanders can make a difference didn't seem to be getting through to listeners. When asked whether bystanders who remain silent bear some responsibility for the evil actions of others, there was no difference between those who'd listened to the soap opera and the control group who hadn't. People essentially did not think that bystanders could make any difference.
And what about lesson number three? Intermarriage can reduce hostility. That didn't work either. People told Betsy, I don't really believe that ethnic intermarriage will bring peace. I just lived through a genocide where I watched who to men kill their tootsie wives and children. So, you know, I don't personally buy that.
On all three counts, the soap opera hadn't changed people's beliefs. As entertainment, the show was a hit, but as an experiment, designed to change hearts and minds, move two traumatized people toward reconciliation, the show was a failure. Musaikawaii was nothing more than a fun soap opera. Or was it? There was one dimension where Betsy found the soap opera did make a positive difference, a big difference, and this dimension was even more important than what people believed. When we come back, why the soap opera was far more successful than it might first appear.
I'm Shankar Vedantam, and you're listening to Hidden Brain. This fool, then it might first appear. I'm Shankar Vidantum and you're listening to Hidden Brain. This is NPR. I'm Shankar Vidantum and this is... Okay fine, hidden brain. We're talking about the Rwandan Radio-Sopara that captivated the country with its stories of love and reconciliation after the genocide. That was the good news.
The bad news? Despite the hopes of the creators, the show didn't change people's beliefs. But there was one metric much more important than people's own beliefs. Actual behavior. As the writers of the radio drama went out into the world to speak with listeners of the show, they came across people who lived on two hills near Kigali, very similar to the hills portrayed in the show. Here's director people who lived on two hills near Kigali, very similar to the hills portrayed in the show.
Here's director, André Musagara. If the Soap Opera was a reflection of real life, this was a reflection of the Soap Opera. The Hutu and Tutsi inhabitants on the two hills that Andre visited were just like the Muhumoro and the Bomancy. During the genocide, one group had tried to kill the other. The Hutu hill, during genocide, they went to kill people on the other side and they hooted properties and all that. And the up-take genocide during this transition or justice process, and who to hear was tried? He's talking about the Kachacha, a series of community courts held in the years following the genocide. It put about one million people on trial. There's debate about the specific
numbers, but the vast majority of those tried were found guilty with crimes ranging from vandalism to murder. The crime it was not very good between these two hives, but there was one listener of Musa Keoia on one hill and he went to find his colleague from the other hill. They said together, they shared the via and they said, no, this should not continue this way. And they decided to reunite there. Heroes and they succeeded. Life was imitating art. Musekyewaya had characters playing the role of active bystanders, peacemakers. Now, that
was happening in the real hills outside Kigali. Even though Musekiawea listeners told Betsy Pallik's research team that bystanders couldn't make a difference, bystanders were stepping up to prevent violence. They united and they were inspired by what they heard from our show Musekiawea. We are so proud and we are happy that we are playing a significant role in the reconciliation
in Guanda. And it was more than just anecdotal. Betsy's data found that even though listeners' beliefs didn't change, their behavior did. Take the question of Intermarriage, for instance. Musekya Weyer-Listener has told Betsy's team that they didn't think intermarriage would lead to peace. But that's not all they said. They said, however, I do think that now we should allow our children to intermary. I think that this is the thing that Rwandans are doing. We all think it's a good thing moving forward.
This is a good example of a distinction between what you personally believe, but what you perceive to be a growing trend. What's fascinating here is that you are finding that the message is in fact not changing their own personal opinions, but it's still changing their behavior. That's right. I think if you've reflect on your own behavior, it's hard to find a time when,
这是一个很好的例子，展示了你个人信仰与你所认为的不断增长的趋势之间的区别。这里迷人的是，你发现信息实际上并没有改变他们个人的意见，但它仍然改变了他们的行为。没错。我想如果你反思自己的行为，很难找到这样一个时刻：
as you were deciding on what to do, you didn't consider someone else, or you didn't consider the reaction that your behavior might draw off from someone else. When it comes to changing how people behave, it turns out there is a much more powerful driver than people's own beliefs. People don't always do what they believe, but they usually do what they think everyone else believes. We are such social people. If we think that our behavior is going to be really going in the other lane, in the other direction, from what people who matter to us, from what they're doing. That really restrains our behavior, so we might think one thing, but eventually do another. Not because we're lemmings, but because we're all trying to kind of move in the same direction
当你决定做什么时，你没有考虑其他人，或者你没有考虑你的行为可能会从别人那里引起的反应。当谈到改变人们的行为时，事实证明，存在一个比人们自己的信仰强大得多的驱动力。人们并不总是按照他们的信仰行事，但他们通常按照他们认为其他人所拥有的信仰行事。我们是如此具有社会属性的人。如果我们认为我们的行为将真正走在另一条轨道上，朝着与对我们重要的人所做的事情相反的方向发展。这确实限制了我们的行为，所以我们可能心里这么想，但最终却做了另一件事。不是因为我们盲目从众，而是因为我们都在试图以某种方式朝着与群体相同的方向前进。
with the flock. And if we violate those norms, if we behave in ways that disappoint members of our community, we fear that, and so even if we may believe something different, our behavior will conform to the social norm. In essence, Betsy's research demonstrated that even after just one year, the show was working. Even if it didn't change people's beliefs, it was changing social norms, what people thought was expected of them. The same thing happens in other contexts. Take, for instance, same-sex marriage in the United States. Hundreds of people were in front of the US Supreme Court this morning waiting. In 2015, the Supreme Court ruled that the US Constitution
与群体保持一致。如果我们违反了这些规范，如果我们表现得以社区成员失望的方式，我们会对此感到恐惧，因此，即使我们可能相信不同的事情，我们的行为也会顺从社会规范。本质上，贝齐的研究表明，仅仅过了一年，这个节目就在起作用了。即使它没有改变人们的信仰，它也在改变社会规范，也就是人们认为别人对他们的期望。在其他语境中也会发生同样的事情。以美国同性恋婚姻为例。今天上午，数百人聚集在美国最高法院门前等待。2015年，最高法院裁定，美国宪法
guarantees the right to marry as a fundamental liberty for both straight and gay couples. And historic victory for gay rights today. The Supreme Court. Betsy followed ordinary Americans at the time to see if the court decision changed their own views. Again, people's personal beliefs didn't change, but their behavior did. What moved everyone in the same direction was this perception of whether other Americans
保证了无论是异性情侣还是同性情侣将结婚作为一项基本自由的权利。今天是同性恋权利的历史性胜利。最高法院。贝齐当时追踪了普通的美国人，看法院的判决是否改变了他们自己的观点。同样，人们的个人信仰没有改变，但他们的行为改变了。让每个人朝着同一方向前进的是这种看法：其他美国人是否
support same-sex marriage and whether it would become more accepted in the future. The Supreme Court ruling in effect told people, the United States now believes same-sex marriage is okay. You could still think otherwise, but if you acted in ways that showed you didn't agree with the consensus, you risked being left behind. Even worse, you risked becoming an outcast. And you may remember that time where people's Facebook walls exploded in rainbows. Once the social norm about gay marriage changed, it emboldened supporters and prompted many dissenters to shrug their
支持同性恋婚姻，以及它在未来是否会变得更加被接受。最高法院的裁决实际上告诉人们，美国现在认为同性恋婚姻是可以接受的。你仍然可以有不同的想法，但如果你行事的表现出你不同意共识，你就会冒着被抛在后面的风险。更糟糕的是，你冒着成为社会边缘人的风险。你可能还记得当时人们的脸书主页上爆发了彩虹。一旦关于同性恋婚姻的社会规范发生变化，它就给了支持者胆量，并促使许多反对者耸耸
shoulders and accept the new normal. The same principle works in all sorts of places. Take bullying, for example. Betsy has found that norms play a powerful role in encouraging bullying and discouraging it. I've been studying bullying and conflict as it plays out in Americans, public schools, and what kept hitting me was that at some point certain types of conflict and prejudice become normal to the people who are living there.
肩膀并接受新常态。同样的原则在各种地方都起作用。以欺凌为例。贝齐发现，规范在鼓励欺凌和阻止欺凌方面发挥了强大的作用。我一直在研究在美国公立学校中上演的欺凌和冲突，最让我震惊的是，在某些时候，某些类型的冲突和偏见对于生活在那里的人来说变得正常了。
The central insight of this research is that people go along with the flow rather than their own beliefs. Betsy found the same thing in Rwanda. People who listened to Musek Awayah began supporting intermarriage even if they didn't personally think that intermarriage was a good thing. It all comes back to this idea that what it means to be human is to belong socially to a group. And so we're all trying to figure out
这项研究的核心见解是，人们随波逐流，而不是坚持自己的信仰。贝齐在卢旺达也发现了同样的情况。收听《穆塞卡维亚》的人开始支持跨族通婚，即使他们个人并不认为跨族通婚是一件好事。这一切都归结于这样一个观点，即作为一个人的意义在于在社会上属于一个群体。所以我们都在试图弄清楚
the rules of those groups. Betsy realized that one unintended way the soap opera had a big effect was that people had listened together. They thought they were just listening to the show, but they were also taking in the reactions of friends and neighbors. When other people expressed dismay as Ruta Ghanira got in the way of the Star Cross lovers, that sent a message. My fellow Rwandans don't like people like Ruta Ghanira.
这些群体的规则。贝齐意识到，这部肥皂剧产生重大影响的一个意想不到的方式是，人们是一起收听的。他们以为自己只是在听节目，但他们也在吸收朋友和邻居的反应。当其他人对鲁塔·加尼拉阻碍苦命鸳鸯表达沮丧时，这就传递了一个信息。我的卢旺达同胞不喜欢像鲁塔·加尼拉这样的人。
After the year of testing was over, Betsy's team gave each group a portable stereo and 14 cassette tapes of the radio program. It was ostensibly a reward for volunteering, but it was actually part of the experiment too. After presenting the stereo, a research assistant suggested that the group could decide how best to share it. In the communities that had been listening to this reconciliation radio program, it was a little bit counterintuitive at first, but they fought more over their common resources that we gave them. And the reason why that was exciting to us is that one of the messages of this radio program was, you should descend against authority. You should make your voice heard.
一年的测试结束后，贝齐的团队给每个小组发了一个便携式音响和14盒广播节目的磁带。这表面上是对他们做志愿者的奖励，但实际上也是实验的一部分。在赠送了音响后，一名研究助理建议该小组可以决定如何最好地分享它。在那些一直在收听这个和解广播节目的社区里，起初这有点违反直觉，但他们为我们给他们的共同资源争吵得更多了。对我们来说这令人兴奋的原因是，这个广播节目的其中一个信息是，你应该反抗权威。你应该发出自己的声音。
In the communities that had not been listening in a dedicated way to these reconciliation soap operas, basically one person proposed, we give it to the local authority, they will decide for us. Everyone said, good, and moved on. Among the Musekia Weir group, the discussion was much more lively. Usually someone would make the same proposal. This is what is customary to do in Rwandan communities. But then someone would raise their hand and say, I don't know, the local authority hasn't been coming to listen to all these shows with us.
在那些没有专门收听这些和解肥皂剧的社区里，基本上一个人提议，我们把它交给地方当局，他们会为我们决定。每个人都说，好，然后继续前进。在《穆塞卡维亚》小组中，讨论要活泼得多。通常有人会提出同样的建议。这是卢旺达社区惯常的做法。但随后有人会举手说，我不知道，地方当局并没有来和我们一起听所有这些节目。
Why should we sign it over to him? And then maybe someone else would raise their hand and say, I think we should give it to a woman. They are way more responsible than men. And there would be a healthy debate about that. And then people would decide on what to do. So I went back and I said, look, we have caused healthy debate. This is something to celebrate.
我们为什么要把它交给他？然后可能其他人会举手说，我认为我们应该把它交给女性。她们比男性负责任得多。然后会有一场关于这一点的健康辩论。接着人们会决定该怎么做。所以我回去说，看，我们引发了健康的辩论。这是值得庆祝的事情。
When I spoke to the Rwandan leader Alphonse Bakuji recently, it was close to the anniversary of the 1994 genocide. He told me he was incredibly proud of all that Rwandans had accomplished in the intervening quarter century. Mosecawea, along with many other interventions, had made a difference. Irvin's tower beccomplished what few scholars ever do. He got to see his ideas put into action. More important, he got to see his ideas make a difference. If there's a continuum of destruction, Irvin helped to show there is also a continuum of benevolence. People can learn tolerance
当我最近与卢旺达领导人阿方斯·巴库吉交谈时，正值1994年大屠杀周年纪念日附近。他告诉我，他对卢旺达人在过去四分之一世纪里取得的一切成就感到无比自豪。《穆塞卡维亚》以及许多其他干预措施，带来了改变。欧文·斯陶尔实现了极少数学者能够做到的事情。他看到自己的思想付诸行动。更重要的是，他看到他的思想带来了改变。如果存在一个毁灭的连续体，欧文帮助表明也存在一个仁慈的连续体。人们可以学会宽容
by watching what others do, even fictional characters living on make-believe hilltops. Overn told me he admires Betsy Pallik's study, but he disagrees with some of her conclusions. Betsy found that people's behavior changed not because their beliefs evolved, but because their perceptions of social norms did. But urban things that isn't possible to easily separate personal beliefs from one's perception of social norms. Let me just say, there is no argument about the findings, the results. The only difference between her and me is the interpretation of the results. The results are clear, they are there, and they are meaningful and significant. One point Erwin makes is that Betsy's study was conducted during the first year of the show.
通过观察别人的行为，甚至是生活在虚构山顶上的虚构角色。欧文告诉我，他钦佩贝齐·帕利克的学习，但不同意她的一些结论。贝齐发现，人们的行为发生了变化，不是因为他们的信仰演变了，而是因为他们对社会规范的看法发生了变化。但欧文认为，不容易将个人信仰与一个人对社会规范的看法分开。让我这么说吧，对于调查结果、结果是没有争议的。她和我的唯一区别在于对结果的解释。结果很明确，它们就在那里，并且是有意义的重大事件。欧文提出的一个观点是，贝齐的研究是在该剧的第一年进行的。
By the end of that year, there were many unresolved issues in the narrative. Erwin thinks that if the study had been conducted later, for example, after the villain Ruta Ghanira experiences a change of heart, the study might have picked up changes in people's attitudes, not just their behavior. Now, you might argue that the academics are splitting hairs. I asked Irvin about that.
到那一年结束时，叙事中还有许多未解决的问题。欧文认为，如果这项研究是在后来进行的，例如，在恶人鲁塔·加尼拉经历转变之后，这项研究可能会捕捉到人们态度的变化，而不仅仅是他们的行为。现在，你可能会争辩说学者们在吹毛求疵。我问了欧文关于这一点的问题。
I'm going to play you an extended excerpt from our exchange, because it leads up to something really important. As I said, I think the theoretical differences about why the behavior changed are less important than the fact that behavior actually changed in the direction that was intended. And as you point out, this evaluation was done after one year of a program that lasted now 14 years. And those points are very well made. But do you think actually it's important whether the difference comes from norms or beliefs or values, or is it actually just more important that people's behavior changed and who cares what the actual mechanism was? Well, I think that for this, in our case, after one year, what's really important is
我将播放我们对话的一个长篇节选，因为它引出了一些非常重要的事情。正如我所说，我认为关于行为为什么改变的理论差异并不那么重要，重要的是行为确实朝着预期的方向发生了改变。正如你所指出的，这次评估是在一个已经持续了14年的节目的第一年之后进行的。这些观点提得非常好。但是你认为不同之处是来自规范、信仰还是价值观真的很重要，或者其实更重要的是人们的行为改变了，谁在乎实际的机制是什么？好吧，我认为对于这个，在我们的案例中，一年之后，真正重要的是
that behavior changed and some thinking has changed. But there is one reason why it is also important what leads to change. And that is when a society moves towards violence, what we hope is that people understand and can't foresee what's going to happen. That was one reason we talked to them about the origins of violence Now things evolve slowly and at each point a person can say well, it's just one little thing I'm not doing anything and then they're the next point the same thing But if you can't foresee where this is going to lead you are more likely to get involved early, right now
行为改变了，一些思想也改变了。但有一个原因说明什么导致了改变也很重要。那就是当一个社会走向暴力时，我们希望人们理解并且能够预见到将会发生什么。这是我们与他们讨论暴力根源的原因之一。现在事情发展缓慢，在每个点上一个人都可以说，这只是一件小事，我什么也没做，然后在下一个点上也是同样的事情。但如果你无法预见这将 dẫn向何方，你更有可能早早介入，就在此时此地。
if your views depend on social norms, as a society begins to move towards violence, the social norm is that you move together with everybody as towards violence. But if you personally believe that you should take action, then you are more likely to go contrary to the direction of your group. Irwin wants to believe that the values of ordinary Rwandans changed because he wants to believe that the transformation in Rwanda is here to stay, that if hatred were to start broadcasting again, ordinary Rwandans would stand up to it because they now have different values. But if Betsy is right, this means that Rwandans began acting in a more tolerant fashion in large part because tolerance became the new social norm. This raises a troubling question. If social norms can change in a matter of
如果你的观点取决于社会规范，当一个社会开始走向暴力时，社会规范就是你与所有人一起走向暴力。但如果你个人认为你应该采取行动，那么你更有可能违背你的群体的方向。欧文想要相信普通卢旺达人的价值观发生了变化，因为他想要相信卢旺达的转变会持续下去，如果仇恨再次开始广播，普通的卢旺达人会挺身而出，因为他们现在拥有不同的价值观。但如果贝齐是对的，这就意味着卢旺达人开始表现得更加宽容，在很大程度上是因为宽容成为了新的社会规范。这提出了一个令人不安的问题。如果社会规范可以在
months from hate to tolerance, can't they go back just as easily in the other direction? Betsy study provides an important lesson and not just for people in Rwanda. The currents that govern human behavior are fickle. If you want to make change and then preserve it, you need to be eternally vigilant. After several years of will they or won their drama, Shema and Batamuriza finally get married. Ruandans got so excited about the wedding, about the forbidden love between these two villages, that they wanted to witness an actual wedding. They demanded that the producers of the radio show hold a wedding in the national stadium so that the whole country could show up to watch.
几个月内从仇恨转变为宽容，难道它们不能同样容易地朝着相反的方向倒退吗？贝齐的研究提供了一个重要的教训，不仅对卢旺达人如此。主宰人类行为的潮流是反复无常的。如果你想做出改变并将其保存下来，你需要永远保持警惕。经过几年“他们会在一起吗”的戏剧，谢马和巴塔穆里扎终于结婚了。卢旺达人对这场婚礼、对这两个村庄之间被禁止的爱情感到非常兴奋，以至于他们想见证一场真正的婚礼。他们要求广播节目的制片人在国家体育场举行婚礼，以便全国都可以出席观看。
Here's the director, André Musagara. We thought of them, Shema and the atomizers waiting in country taking place at the National Stadium because they have many friends. So, if you want to take part in their waiting, this is the way you are going to do it. Kamiya, kamiya, kamiya, kamiya, kamiya, kamiya, kamiya, kamiya, kamiya, kamiya, kamiya, kamiya, kamiya, kamiya, kamiya, kamiya, kamiya, kamiya, kamiya, kamiya, kamiya, kamiya, kamiya, kamiya, kamiya, kamiya, kamiya, kamiya, kamiya, kamiya, kamiya, kamiya, kamiya, kamiya, kamiya, kamiya, kamiya, kamiya, kamiya, kamiya, kamiya, kamiya, kamiya, kamiya, kamiya, kamiya, kamiya, kamiya, kamiya, kamiya, kamiya, kamiya, kamiya, kamiya, kamiya, kamiya, kakao, kakao, kakao, kakao, kakao, kakao, kakao, kakao, kakao, kakao, kakao, kakao, kakao, kakao, kakao, kakao, kakao, kakao, kakao, kakao, kakao, kakao, kakao, kakao, kakao, kakao, kakao, kakao, kakao, kakao, kakao, kakao, kakao, kakao, kakao, kakao, kakao, kakao, kakao, kakao, kakao, kakao, kakao, kakao, kakao, kakao, kakao, kakao, kakao, kakao, kakao, kakao, kakao, kakao, kakao, kakao Friends, peace is a plant that is transplanted and maintained by people together. It is the fruit of love for your neighbor. Be the first to maintain them. Where these hatred, they do not grow. Where these love, they grow and flourish.
这是导演安德烈·穆萨加拉。我们想到了他们，谢马和巴塔穆里扎在国家体育场举行的婚礼，因为他们有很多朋友。所以，如果你想参加他们的婚礼，这就是你将要去做的方式。朋友们，和平是一株由人们共同移植和维护的植物。它是对邻居之爱的果实。争做维护它们的人。哪里有仇恨，它们就不会生长。哪里有爱，它们就会生长和繁荣。
For Andre Moussagara and the other creators of the show, the goal is to keep that message going as long as the audience is interested. Mussecawea is now in its 14th year and shows no signs of stopping. It's a soap opera. The twists are endless. Today's show was produced by Matthew Schwartz and edited by Tara Boyle. Our team includes Jennifer Schmidt, Reyna Cohen, Parth Shah, Laura Quarelle and Thomas Lu. Jackson Vungani did our voiceovers and translations. Special thanks to Radio Lab in Evalencia, the Dutch NGO that spearheaded the creation of Ponseca Waya and got us in touch with the writers of the show and Rwandan leaders.
对于安德烈·穆萨加拉和该剧的其他创作者来说，只要观众感兴趣，他们的目标就是让这个信息延续下去。《穆塞卡维亚》现在已经进入第14个年头，并且没有停止的迹象。这是一部肥皂剧。曲折无穷无尽。今天的节目由马修·施瓦茨制作，塔拉·博伊尔编辑。我们的团队包括詹妮弗·施密特、雷娜·科恩、帕斯·沙、劳拉·夸雷尔和托马斯·卢。杰克逊·文加尼负责我们的配音和翻译。特别感谢荷兰非政府组织放射实验室和瓦伦西亚，他们带头创建了《穆塞卡维亚》，并让我们与该剧的编剧和卢旺达领导人取得了联系。
I'm Shankar Vedantam, see you next week, and remember, don't be a Ruta Gainira. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆，下周见，记住，不要成为鲁塔·加尼拉。这一集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任何句子来留下评论。